[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
kartoffelsalat effekt zum grill aber
auch das ganze jahr über wiiware
kartoffelsalat und der ist ein bisschen
speziell der ist auch kiki arte ist
lecker und einfach gemacht und hier habe
ich jetzt auch schon eine schüssel ich
möchte auch gar nicht so viel geschirr
verschwenden deshalb macht hier
zuallererst sozusagen das dressing in
dieser schüsse und gebt dann alle
anderen zutaten mit dazu es ist ein
rezept für faule da müssen nicht so viel
spüren
und ich habe jetzt hier einmal das ist
das wasser von den gewürzgurken das
dürften niemals wegschmeißen das ist so
lecker so komische sachen ich bitte sie
so trinken aber von dead rising ist es
optimal das gebe ich jetzt hier rein so
und dann gebe ich auch schon selbst wird
dazu falls euch wohl warum fängt sofort
an wo sie zu taten vorstellung wir
findet immer die ganz genaue
mengenangaben und in der video
beschreibung so wuchs in der infobox
soll hier habe ich sind ich persönlich
bin jetzt nicht so der sinn fein aber in
diesem dressing ist dass man muss und es
schmeckt auch nicht so also man schlägt
sich so krass raus aber es macht halten
schönen beigeschmack
sowas haben wir noch schön ist hier habe
ich ein bisschen esse ich nehme heute
apfelessig einfach rein
dann habe ich etwas öl ich persönlich
mag leinöl ganz gerne
ihr könntet auch zum beispiel rapsöl
nehmen distelöl das funktioniert auch
alles wunderbar so amrhein aber ich
totaler knoblauch verbin wäre ich jetzt
noch eine knoblauchpresse
[Musik]
so natürlich salz und pfeffer so ich
weiß es klingt jetzt ein bisschen banal
aber die meisten haben mir mein
schwarzkümmelöl video gesehen die
meisten kennen mein eigenes produkt und
die wissen dass das tagtäglich einigen
für das immunsystem für die gesundheit
und jetzt fragen mich ganz viele wie
kann ich das denn jemand alltag
integrieren in essen was ist ja öl kennt
man ja bekanntlich auch zum essen das
darf nicht erhitzt werden aber heute
wird ja nichts erhitzt und es passt
wunderbar zu kartoffeln deshalb
integriere ich jetzt einfach noch einen
schuss von meinem schwarzkümmelöl in dem
rezept das passt auch wunderbar und ist
früher ich das trotzdem miteinander also
die ganzen komponenten miteinander so
und das war es im prinzip vom dressing
jetzt müssen die festen bestandteile
rein das heißt wir brauchen jetzt die
kartoffeln die müsst ihr vorher garen
das sind vorwiegend festkochende
kartoffeln ich habe die schon vorgegart
damit dieser das video auch nicht zu
lang wird und ich werde jetzt einfach
mit meinem wellen schneider
durchschneiden da könnt ihr einfach
schauen möchte risiko ist sie kleiner
das ist komplett euch überlassen oder
ich liebe es auch für alles in wählen
sie lecker aus und es ist auch
tatsächlich gut für kinder geeignet weil
die sich eben nicht so schnell schneiden
können also wenn ihr kinder habt ihr
anfangen möchten in der küche zweifel
wunderbar dafür geeignet ich verlinke
euch natürlich wie immer alles in der
infobox
so die kartoffeln sind jetzt in der
schüssel
da gebe ich jetzt noch gewiss gucken mit
dazu und übertreibt immer gerne aber ich
liebe gewürzgurken also echt ne menge
ihr könnt es auch reduzieren
dann hab ich hier rote ziehen und ihr
könnt auch charlotte nehm ich finde die
beiden waren ein bisschen milder und ich
nehme ganz gerne und mais mit dazu jetzt
nicht so viel und jetzt einmal schön
kräftig umrühren
ja du bist ein maisfeld
was soll der geiz ist geil
[Musik]
so der hansa hat gesagt mach doch noch
paprika dreimal haben sie die paprika
und ich finde dann haben wir auch eine
ampel gelb ist was grün ist und was rot
ist perfekt und ich gebe da jetzt noch
schnittlauch mit dazu ich habe jetzt nur
getrockneten aber frischer passt
natürlich auch richtig gut einfach oben
drüber
und jetzt muss der salat ziehen also die
länge erzieht umso leckerer wird es ist
leider so ich bin auch mal sehr
ungeduldig aber gebt dem ganzen zeit
mindestens drei stunden ihr könnt es
auch am vortag vorbereiten um so besser
dann habe ich am nächsten tag wenn ihr
gerät keinen stress und jetzt schon ein
salat vorbereitet und er konnte richtig
gut durchziehen
mehr habe ich heute nicht zu sagen heute
so ein kurzes video das die richtig
schnell ich bin jetzt ich ja auch noch
mal richtig gut aus haben sagt druck
sieht richtig richtig gut aus ich
schreibe euch wie gesagt alles ganz
genau unten in die infobox und dann
freue ich mich wenn ihr mir weitere
vorschläge gibt was wir machen können
ich habe mir schon so eine ganze liste
erstellt ihr seid ihr immer so fleißig
im vorschläge geben aber immer gerne
immer gerne auch schreiben wir richten
uns komplett nach euch und dann freue
ich mich wenn ihr diesen video ein
dörfchen nach oben geht am see ist fast
umgefallen ist doch gut gegangen
ich wünsche euch jetzt einen
wunderschönen tag und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal cherokee
[Musik]